-Alright, Nikki, Jay,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song
you guys get.
[ Beeping ]
"I'm Every Woman"
by Whitney Houston.
Okay. I'm only
like three to four women,
depending on
the time of the month.
So I think you should
take this one, Jay.
-I got like 200 personalities.
I'm sure like at least a few of
them are women in there.
It's fine.
-You got this. You got this.
-Okay. Alright. I'll do it.
-You got this?
Alright, buddy. Here we go.
"I'm Every Woman"
by Whitney Houston.
Whenever you're ready.
♪♪
-Come on.
Unh. Unh.
Unh, unh, unh.
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ I do it naturally ♪
Oh!
[ Shouting gibberish ]
-My spray tan!
-That's what we needed.
We needed that.
-Cold? I'm sorry.
It's freezing.
-It's so much more than
I thought it would be.
[ Laughter ]
[ Distorted shouting ]
-I'm sorry, you didn't get that
one completely correct.
That's 50,000 points for
Dan and Terry.
-Yeah! Yes!
-Whoo!
-Alright, guys, for this
final song, all four of you
are going to take turns singing,
so pay attention.
Your screen will switch off
line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get sprayed.
And this round is worth
200,000 points,
so whoever wins this
wins the whole thing
for their charity.
Let's see what
our final song is.
[ Beeping ]
-"Umbrella"?
Oh.
-Yes!
-Alright.
That's good. That's good.
-Yes!
-Alright.
Dan, you are gonna start us off.
-And then you're gonna
switch off. Here we go.
Whenever you're ready.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Oh, I love it.
This is a true story.
♪ Makin' my way downtown ♪
♪ Walkin' around,
I don't know what time it is ♪
-Nikki.
-♪ Starin' blankly ahead ♪
♪ Just makin' my way ♪
♪ Makin' my way
through the crowd ♪
-Yeah! Terry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ And I need you ♪
-♪ And I miss you ♪
-♪ And now I wonder ♪
-♪ If I could fall
into the sky ♪
♪ Do you think time
would pass me by? ♪
-♪ 'Cause you know I'd walk
a thousand miles ♪
♪ If I could just
see you tonight ♪
-Come on!
Come on, man! Come on, man!
[ Distorted ] Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]